[Music]
Hello everyone. Welcome back to PJ's cat
class for jewelry. Today we would like
to build a pendant with 5 mm roundstone
bezel set and the rabbit ear bell. The
command we possible going to use today
is mesh outline revolve curve round the
two views and sweep one rail. Let's get
started.
Before we start building this model,
let's talk about the concept of the
stone setting.
If you look at the front view, I have
this uh stone profile here. Um they all
have the name with it. Um you have this
is a table. This is the crown where the
thin area it's called girdle and pavlian
which is the bottom area and also the
cuelet. The very important part of the
song setting, for example, if you have a
prong, you definitely doesn't want to
have a metal go over
the crown area and reach the table
because it's going to make the stone
look really small. You don't want to
have a prong too thin as well because
the stone might be fall out. The very
important part is right here where is
the girdle area.
That is where stone is measured and also
it's being held
approximately after your jeweler finish
this stone setting.
The prong will be approximately 50 to
70% of the crown area which is the
height
and the thickness of the
prong shouldn't be cut more than 50%.
So for example, if this prong is about 1
mm
after the stone is setting in there
shouldn't be cut more than 0.5 mm.
That is the basic concept for the stone
setting after it is set.
So now let's start building a bezel for
the stone like this.
This is a 5 mm stone, round stone in
mesh. And a lot of time, even though we
use old snap or we try to snap on it,
the mesh doesn't allow us to snap. But
we really need this profile so we can
build our prong very precisely. So this
is what we do. You go to the command
right here. You type it mesh online.
And it will ask you to pick up any mesh
poly surface or surface. We want to pick
on the stone. And it look like there's
nothing happened. But if you move your
mouse to click here, you're going to
notice there is a curve right there. I'm
going to temporarily hide it my stone.
So you will see that outline.
Now we're going to enlarge the front
view. So the goal is to make the
rendering look finished.
We are going to use partial of this
profile and then we're going to build a
prong with it.
There are few way to build a prong. You
can use the um curve tool, control point
curve, and kind of eyeball what is the
best
at this point.
And then we want to have another one.
Make sure your gumball is on. Near point
is on.
And we want to build something like
this.
And we'll finish it.
with the curve.
Now, I need to have this profile there.
So, I'm going to use the poly line and
make sure I snap to the end point
over there.
So now I can select all the curve and
join them together
become one single curve that will fit
the stone profile perfectly.
Remember we're talking about the setting
concept. If for some reason
make this curve either too tall or too
short,
you can go ahead to turn on the control
point and kind of drag them in order to
find a perfect place for it. I'm going
to turn on my gumball so it's easier for
me to manipulate.
Okay, so that's perfect.
Now, what we wanted to do is I'm going
to turn on my stone again. We're going
to have this curve. And this time, I
would like to use the command under the
surface. It's called revolve
the starting axis. Since my stone is
right at a 0 0, so I'm just going to
type it zero and move my mouse down
holding the shift. So that will be
exactly 90°
and then starting angle is zero
and I want to go 360°
and then we will get this bezel here.
I'm going to turn this bezel into other
layer by right click to any of the layer
you want to and change object layer. So
now we have this bezel.
Now let's take a look on the right view.
We want to build
a loop right here for the chain to go
through. Uh we can simply just do the
chain uh do the curve something like
this. But the curve is kind of not so
nice. So I want it to be something to be
exact. So I'm going to use some curve to
help me
starting with this poly line. I want to
just starting from inside because
they're going to connect it. And then I
approximately want to have four
millimeter. So I'm just going to type
four.
And then you're going to see there's a
set distance. No matter where your mouse
click, that will be four from where the
start point. So going to hold it shift
and I will click.
Then I want to type it two
and again I want to holding on the shift
and click.
So now I have two section together. One
is four, one is two. I'm going to use
another uh line work from the midpoint.
And then I want to make sure my all snap
is on and endpoint is on. So I'm going
to snapping into the end point.
And then I want to type it too.
So if I'm going to use this as a
guideline, I can using a arc snapping
into where is the center and snapping
from here to here.
So I will have this
arc is exactly
2 millimeter from here to here and from
the center to this side as well.
The second thing I wanted to do is to
create a curve from here to here. I'm
going to temporarily hide this one.
We could have just do a straight line
going here to here. But notice that you
are going to have something really sharp
here and it doesn't look good.
So what I like to do is using
blend tool
by creating a little tag there first
and then I'm going to use the blend tool
is living in the icon under the curve
tool or you can go into the curve and it
is here
blank curve. Okay, so either one will
work. So, I'm going to use the blend
tool and I'm going to blend from
this end to that end. Of course, you can
adjust it, but we kind of notice we have
a really smooth curve right there.
All right. And then I'm going to have
this curve just gonna mirror using this
center as my axis and mirror to the
other side. So now let's join all of
this.
Now let's take a look on the top view.
Anything you draw right here
on the right view, it will show exactly
on the C plane which is construction
plane
on the top view.
We don't want our bell is look really
straight. We actually want it to have a
little bit curve there. So I'm going to
go on the top view and I'm going to draw
a curve
approximately look like this.
Now I'm going to hide the stone first.
And if you see
the curve we have in between this one
and that one. I want to tell Rhino I
wanted to build a curve like this but in
this direction.
So what we are going to do is going to
use the command is called curve from two
views.
It's either living in the icon right
here or you can go into the curve and
you will find this curve from two views.
You're going to select both of the curve
and it will automatically generate this
curve.
that is follow both curve that you
select.
Now I'm going to prepare for my sweep
and I need a profile for sweep.
I'm going to use the rectangular tool
with the center and I'm going to snap to
the end point.
Now I have to look at the front view.
And I can eyeball with the size I want
it or I can type it
the size I wanted.
Now let's look at the top view. The key
for the successful sweep and the sweep
will look nice is you want to have your
profile 90°
to your curve. the rail possible. So
that's move a little bit angle over
there.
And we also wanted to make the H a
little bit rounded
so it will look nicer on the rendering.
The command we're going to use is fitted
corners. So we basically want to fill
fill it this
into
round edges.
Now I'm looking at the right view and I
want to tilt it the angle a little bit
so it's 90° at this way on the right
view as well.
Maybe I want to move it up a little bit.
Okay. So now we are ready. I want to
mirror
this one
to the bottom.
So now we have the profile and then we
have the rail ready. Let's take a look
on the perspective.
I'm going to hide those line so that
doesn't bother you.
It's easier for us to see. Now you can
see we have a clear profile
for those two
and the rail. So here we go. We go into
the surface sweep one rail. This is the
rail and this is the crosssection.
I always like to move the arrow to the
center and make sure they are facing the
same direction so they don't flip.
So now we have one.
Let me turn on
the rest of it and see what proportion
look like.
I might need to move this guy just a
little bit there.
And maybe move it a little bit angle.
Okay.
Now I'm going to turn off this again to
show you something.
Notice that this one is not solid. So
when I try to bling, it will have a
issue. So we need to cap this guy. The
command is called cap.
Will ask you to select your surface and
we're going to pick up this surface and
you will cap it.
All I need to do now is mirror this guy.
Type it zero. So that will
mirror exactly evenly on the other side
and that's bowling unit this guy.
Now let me turn on the rest of it
and make sure that it's in a good
position
and we can bowling unit this guy.
Here we go. A simple pendant
with the bezel set and rabbit ear bell.
Thank you for watching the tutorial.
I hope to see you soon again in my other
tutorial.
[Music]